my fastest marathon was 3 43. damn which  is pretty good have you always been sick  at [ __ ] athleticism I was always like  good at being an athlete but I was never  a gifted athlete yeah like with diving I  was never the one that like everyone  looked at like oh that kid's gonna be  incredible yeah I just worked really  hard so I was able to get to a place  that was like respectable yeah but I was  never gonna be the top because I wasn't  like just naturally gifted enough it's  the same thing with Endurance Sports not  the guy that's gonna start running 6 30  miles like just because I'm built for it  or not you know you can't run 6 30 miles  no I mean like yeah I can but yeah now  you can't because I've trained up to it  damn you're sick